the stool is waiting for you
and by now
if you've tried any
of the exercises
you may have your own store cushions
or a place where you can sit
you may have decided to make a small
part designated in one of your wounds
in your house apartment
or
out in nature
when I build my first dojo in 1982.
before meeting cytosity
I did believe a lot in
the desire to find peace for myself
I've grown up with a very troubled mind
and I don't know why it's so troubled
I think it's because
I want more
than what is available
and I always wanted
in a hurry
what I did back then
so I didn't have time for meditation
Charles work
and even now
40.
50 years on
yes it's 50 years old now
I'm still in the hungry
we hope we change but
some parts though some parts we've
become wiser for
but this is My Sanctuary
and I hope in these meditations it
becomes your sanctuary as well
try not to
bed like me and spend most of your life
having a troubled mind
because
we feed this troubled mind rather than
accept that we haven't traveled behind
we may find that it was our upbringing
we may put it down to all sorts of
things
but when we are perhaps down
or as I say have a troubled mind a busy
mind
trying to know that it will pass
and you can help it pass by taking time
out
and sit in meditation
or once you go a little bit deeper than
meditation as with the bowel
then
you go into what I call trials where you
don't feel your body
physically anymore and yet you know
you're sitting there
it's almost you could say hypnotherapy
on yourself and
trying to beat yourself up
that you are because people don't
consider themselves as a really good
person they spend more time
thinking
that they are a bad person or perhaps
that's just me
let's
get down to the meditation for today
mentally Place yourself in on the stall
in front of us
or
comfortable place in your own home
or as I said out in nature
in the early days
in 1982 83
I used to find
down by the river a wonderful large tree
and this is the meditation I can talk
about to you today
so first of all when you're ready
calm yourself close your eyes
mean that you have to clear your throats
or have a sip of water that is close by
there's always a good thing
because the mouth
can get dry
and disturb your time and meditation
so once you're relaxed with your eyes
closed
we're going to take your official
Journey
and don't worry about how you get there
you can add to this if you have to with
your own mind
but you're going to place yourself
at a
gauge that will lead into an open grass
field
you can design the guide however you
wish
but it opens
how you wish it could open
and see yourself
go
from the gate
and all the actions that it takes
just
step into the field
this field is used by many people
because it has a footpath
it has a Tarmac footpath
it's not so wide but wide enough
for two people to pass
you're going one way like others and
others coming back
but very early in the morning
it's very quiet and hardly anybody will
be on this path except you
and perhaps some other thing you may see
the distance will be dependent upon your
visualization
does the path
Bend
they think it's quite straight whatever
you wish it to be
the path will be
to the left or your right
I like I would like you to place
this cross-filled going downwards
where at the bottom of the field there
is a river
so place they failed on the right of the
left
going downwards some of the slope going
downwards in the field and at the bottom
of the field
that was a river
if the river is running fast
then this is you need to come
perhaps you need to stop
before you
leave this path before you step off the
path
and you should just view the whoever
if the part if the river is calm and
hardly
moving
perhaps you're calm
and you're in the book ready position
step onto the grass
somewhere in this field I'd like you to
Prime place
going down to the river
it's a very very large old trees
they don't have to be anything specific
was that
really vast
in diameter
there doesn't have to be lots
you choose how many you wish to put
there
if you put too many
you're making your mind busy again
better to have a few or just one even
the one that you're going to walk slowly
towards
is the grass
long or short
forever the length you will determine
is it lush green
or is it coming to the end of its
Quran Spirits become tall and brown and
only green at the bottom base
you decide
is it moist because it's early in the
morning
is it making your shoes or feet wet if
you decided you haven't got shoes all of
a sudden and you hadn't thought about it
it doesn't matter
the mind is only trying to trick you by
making you want to think
each time take the first thing that you
see in your mind
and don't fight it
please accept it
and just go on to the next part
I'd like you to choose a tree if you
haven't got one
and it's so large you can't see around
the other side
of the tree you can always see the sight
that you're walking towards
if you find yourself going quickly
now everybody
stop consider
there is no rush
than star enjoying each step
as the feet go down
until you get to the tree
and the base of the tree
that you
have been looking at going towards
it has a large strong roots but you can
see above the ground know that they're
going deep into the ground
but between the roads
it's almost
tree that you chose
has a place that will fit you it will
fit your back
perfectly
your man was sit in this part
as if
you have become absorbed by the tree
or has
have you absorbed the tree or the tree
absorbed you
fitting snugly into this work base
now even though you should have been
visualizing with your eyes closed
imagine that you are actually staying
now
your surrounding area
I hear not what you can say
you will place into the picture what you
wish to place
but please remember not to make it too
busy
or if there's means
that your mind is filling it up
and you should be taking things
step by step and then
these parts
you might be actually looking out
with your eyes wide open
in your vision
that you might not be saying anything
because your mind may be looking inwards
even though
the meditation is looking outwards
decide whether you wish to keep looking
around you with your eyes open
it's not inside the tree roots
or if you would like to just take time
out
close your eyes
and just let time pass have no meaning
of time
because
you want to
not accept that there is any time
pressure or place you need to be right
now
do you feel comfortable
is for warmth
You Feel Complete
there's nothing that you're asking for
and you're receiving everything that you
need
peace
warmth
contentment
you may find your smiling and you don't
know why you're smiling
but it's beautiful
it's all for you
and for the next moment
you will enjoy this
you can say that as
any time we wish to be on this journey
when you're ready and only when you're
ready
take the pieces
back
to the gate
and even though you're listening to my
voice
be in time with me
you're gonna be more delayed if you wish
when you go to the gate
and goes past through the other side of
the gates
back onto the stone or wherever you are
decided
to sit
just with you immensely being
giving you
with an outward breath when you're ready
open your eyes
and bring yourself back into the room
either here in the dojo
all back at your own
environment
this visualization
I call it the tree